ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
8a und 8b jeweils zweite und dritte
Beratung der von den Fraktionen SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwürfe zur
Einführung von Preis Bremsen für
leitungsgebundenes Erdgas und Wärme und
Veränderung sonstiger Vorschriften sowie
zur Einführung einer strompreisbremse
und zu Änderungen weiterer
energierrechtlicher Bestimmungen der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
hat in seiner Beschlussempfehlung auch
Änderungen des fünften Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes des
apothekengesetzes der
Apothekenbetriebsordnung und des
stabilisierungs-
zu beiden Gesetzentwürfen erfolgt die
Schlussabstimmung jeweils namentlich für
die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68
Minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
Aussprache und das Wort hat zu Beginn
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Ricarda Land die katalang ist nicht nur
hier Mitglied im Bundestag sondern ja
auch kooper teilvorsitzende genannten
gemeinsam mit noripur
Parteivorsitzende der Bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen am 24 Februar
diesen Jahres begannt Vladimir Putin
seinen unmenschlichen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine und von Beginn an nutzt er
nicht nur militärische Mittel sondern
auch Energiepreise als eine Waffe mit
dem klaren Ziel unseres Solidarität mit
der Ukraine zu brechen und uns zu
spalten doch das Problem begann vor dem
24 Februar denn warum waren wir so
angreifbar weil wir uns über Jahrzehnte
hinweg abhängig gemacht haben von
russischen Gas das vermeintlich billig
war heute können und müssen wir ganz
klar sagen russisches Gas war niemals
billig den preiszahlen heute Millionen
von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
und in Zahlen vor allem diejenigen die
schon davor nicht wussten wie es ihm die
Runden kommen die jeden Euro zweimal
umdrehen mussten in Zahlen aber auch
Familien aus dem Mittelschicht und
kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen die gerade überlegen wie sie
eigentlich im nächsten Jahr noch
investieren können und an alle die haben
wir heute eine ganz klare Message wir
nehmen gelten die Hand übernehmen
Verantwortung und wir lassen niemand in
die verkrise alleine denn mit den Strom
und gaspreisbremsen da entlasten wir
Millionen von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
ganz konkret auf der Rechnung da
unterstützen wir Unternehmen in diesem
Land und schützen so den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und das
sorgen wir mit den Härtefallregelungen
dafür dass das erhalten bleibt dass wir
alle brauchen Krankenhäuser
Pflegeeinrichtungen wir schützen die
soziale Infrastruktur in diesem Land
und einen Teil von dem finanzieren wir
aus den sogenannten übergewinnen aus dem
zufallsgewinnen aus den Geldern die
einige wenige Energiekonzerne in diesen
Krieg gemacht haben und für mich ist das
ehrlich gesagt ein Gebot der
Gerechtigkeit denn viele Menschen
Unternehmen Familien nicht mehr wissen
wie sie um die Runden kommen sollen und
gleichzeitig einige wenige große Gewinne
machen dann ist es doch klar dass wir
ein Teil dieses Geldes nutzen und
Entlastungen für die Breite der
Bevölkerung zu finanzieren gerade in
einer Krise muss gelten wer einen
Beitrag leisten kann der übernimmt
Verantwortung der Unterstützung braucht
der bekommt sie und so machen wir aus
dem viel herbei beschworenen Winter der
Wut ein Winter der Solidarität
und ich bin mir sicher ich habe es in
den letzten Wochen schon immer wieder in
Medien gehört wir werden von Ihnen hier
heute hören das reicht alles nicht das
zu wenig und zu spät aber ich finde die
Union muss sich ehrlich gesagt mal
entscheiden denn am Montag fordert die
Union Steuerentlastungen für wohlhabende
am Dienstag beschwert sie sich über zu
viele Schulden und am Mittwoch sagt sie
dass wir mehr Entlastung brauchen das
macht alles keinen Sinn das wissen wir
auch selbst dieses Finanz wo du wäre
ehrlich gesagt lustig wenn die Lage
nicht so verdammt ernst wäre und deshalb
ist es glaube ich gerade ein Zeichen
dafür dass es gut ist dass wir und nicht
sie Regierungsverantwortung tragen denn
die Menschen in diesem Land die brauchen
keine belanglosen aneinandergeraten
Sprechblasen die brauchen konkrete
Lösung und die bekommen Sie mit der
Strom und mit der gaspreisbremse
doch wir gehen darüber noch einen
Schritt hinaus wir arbeiten als
Regierung allen voran Robert Habeck Tag
für Tag Windrad für Windrad daran dass
wir unabhängiger werden von fossilen
Energien denn es ist klar dass wir jetzt
alles geben müssen um Menschen in Zeiten
einer fossilen Inflation finanziell zu
unterstützen aber es ist auch klar dass
der Weg zu bezahlbarer Energie nur mit
Effizienz und mit erneuerbaren Energien
mit Wind und Sonne geht deshalb ist die
Energiewende eine Frage des
Klimaschutzes sie seine Frage der
Freiheit doch die Energiewende ist auch
eine Frage des sozialen Gerechtigkeit
ich habe gestartet mit dem Angriffskrieg
von Vladimir Putin sein Ziel war es
unsere Solidarität zu brechen und auch
unser Land zu spalten und ich glaube
nach diesem Jahr können wir ganz klar
sagen Vladimir Putin hat die Stärke
unserer Demokratie unterschätzt denn wir
stehen weiterhin an der Seite der
Ukraine wir machen uns unabhängig von
russischen fossilen und wir stärken
jetzt ganz konkret mit der Strom und
gaspreisbremse den Zusammenhalt in
diesem Land kurz um können wir nach
einem Jahr sagen wir lassen uns nicht
spalten
vielen Dank
soweit die Kater lang nächster Redner
kommt jetzt aus der Fraktion der cdu/csu
es ist Andreas Jung er ist Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie und äußert sich
ebenfalls zum Thema Strom und
gaspreisbremse es gibt ja noch
Entschließungsanträge der Union am Ende
dieser Debatte
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte in frau Präsidentin zunächst
herzlich danken für Ihre Würdigung von
annemarie Renger und von Wolfgang
Schäuble wir haben größten Respekt von
diesen Lebensleistungen und der stehende
Applaus des ganzen Hauses hat gezeigt
dass ich für viel mehr als die
Abgeordnete Unionsfraktion spreche wenn
ich sage lieber Herr Dr Schäuble wir
sind stolz dass sie einer von uns sind
dr schäuble ist mit den 50 Jahren länger
dabei als wir alle sie hat Dr schäublem
nach dem 24 Februar gesagt Sie haben
seit sie politisch tätig sind keine
schwere Krise erlebt wir haben wieder
Krieg mitten in Europa und es geht um
Frieden und Freiheit für den wir ein zu
stehen haben aber es geht auch um die
Bekämpfung der Energiekrise die uns
trifft und darum geht es hier dann sind
wichtige Fortschritte gemacht worden
indem wir mitgewirkt haben mit dem
Füllen der gastspeicher mit dem
Beschleunigen der LMG Terminals aber
genauso gilt wir sind noch nicht über
den Berg wir brauchen weiter die volle
Konsequenz und alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieversorgung zu sichern um alle
Potenzial Potenziale der Einsparung zu
nutzen da brauchen wir volle
Konsequenzen ich will zu deutlich sagen
für diesen und für den nächsten Winter
brauchen wir auch noch mehr Konsequenzen
wir
erleben seit spätestens im Frühjahr eine
Explosion der Energiepreise und darauf
braucht es eine starke Antwort und meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
Bundesregierung das ist der Punkt da
haben sie zu viel Zeit verstreichen
lassen sie haben ihr erstes
Entlastungspaket im Sommer ohne
Anschlussregelung auslaufen lassen und
als Olaf Scholz dann des jubeln never
walk alone aus rief sind sie zunächst in
die falsche Richtung los marschiert mit
der gasumlage wollten sie die Preise
zunächst erhöhen viel zu spät ist denn
die gastkommission eingesetzt worden
erst im September und das ist der Grund
warum diese Bremsen nicht vor dem Winter
kommen sondern erst nach dem Winter und
das ist der Grund warum sie sich selbst
und ein Zeitdruck gesetzt haben der dazu
geführt hat dass um 00:25 Uhr in der
Nacht auf gestern den zuständigen
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
ein Konvolut von 400 Seiten mit
Änderungsanträgen zugestellt wurden
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren das
steht einer seriösen Behandlung dieses
gesetzespaketes heute entgegen und wäre
es ihnen verlangt
wäre es ihnen wirklich darum gegangen
sind Zusammenhalt beschworen hier eine
nicht einfach nur ihre Mehrheit zu
nutzen die sie haben soll eine Mehrheit
über die Regierungskoalition
hinauszusuchen da hätten sie wohl die
größte Oppositionspartei von 0,25 in der
letzten Nacht beteiligt
wir haben Respekt vor der Arbeit der
gastkommission und wir unterstützen es
soweit ihre Ergebnisse umgesetzt wurde
um durch diesen Winter zu kommen um dort
wo Menschen Betriebe untergestiegenen
Preisen leiden jetzt zu helfen
ich sage das deutlich aber genauso
deutlich sage ich wir kritisieren das wo
sie abweichen von den Empfehlungen der
gastkommissionen des betrifft gerade die
Industrie die Industrie wird mit den
Regelungen die sie aufgebaut haben mit
Hürden mit Anforderungen mit Begrenzung
da werden beide Teile der Industrie kann
der Energie intensiven Industrie diese
Preisbremse überhaupt nicht die Anspruch
nehmen können und deshalb konterkariert
ihre Umsetzung das doch auch von ihnen
ausgerufene Ziel jetzt die industrielle
Substanz unseres Landes sind
industriellen Kern zu sichern da geht es
um Tausende von Arbeitsplätze es geht um
Wertschöpfung in unserem Land es geht um
Lieferketten ja es geht um die
Zusammenhalt unseres Landes genau an
diesem Punkt in der konterkarieren Sie
die Ergebnisse der eigenen Kommission
ihre eigenen Ansagen und es setzt
die Industrie die Arbeitsplätze die
Wertschöpfung in Deutschland in dieser
Krise auf den Spiel auf das Spielen
deshalb nur für einen schweren Fehler
sie waren es Herr Habig derjenige der
gesagt hat wir werden die Kosten
Dämpfung des Problems zur Kostendämpfung
des Programms werden wir öffnen für
Mittelstand und Handwerk ich stelle fest
es gibt heute keinerlei Antwort auf die
Bäckerei die umgestellt hat auf Pellets
die jetzt unter der Preissteigerung
genauso leidet da gibt es weiter Lücken
in ihrem Programm und dabei darf es
nicht bleiben sie müssen da nachbessern
im letzten Bemerkung über die Frau lang
weil die Frau lang die erneuerbaren
Energien angesprochen hat was sie
Vorleben sie haben nachgebessert aber es
bleibt eine Bremse für erneuerbare
Energien sie konnte Karrieren das was
sie mit dem osterpaket auf dem Weg
bringen wollten Beschleunigung der
erneuerbaren Energien Abschöpfung von
fiktiven Erträgen statt tatsächlichen
gewinnen das ist das Gegenteil dessen
was wir jetzt brauchen zu Beschleunigung
sie respektieren nicht dort wo
Investitionen gemacht werden in anderen
Ländern kann es angerechnet werden da
werden die privilegiert die investieren
hier werden Investitionen zurückgestellt
Branche ist die Rede von ein
Schildbürgerstreich es werden klagen
angekündigt ja wir brauchen eine
beschleunigen Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien und den konterkarieren Sie mit
diesem Paket herzlichen Dank
soweit Andreas Jung von der
Unionsfraktion
der noch einmal die Position seiner
Fraktion zur Strom und
gaspreisbremse
spezifiziert hat nächster Redner ist
Matthias von der SPD im
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitz
zuständig für das Thema ich glaube es
ist ein gutes Zeichen dass nach dem
Gedenken und den Ehrungen wir dieses
Thema hier heute als ersten Punkt auf
der Tagesordnung haben denn die
Ampelkoalition beweist mit diesem
Rettungsschirm das Politik gestalten
kann und dass wir gerade in diesen
Zeiten Sicherheit schaffen können und
das machen wir heute nach vielen Wochen
Beratung durch die Kommission durch die
Regierung dieses Parlament gibt heute
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung und der
Wirtschaft in Deutschland Sicherheit mit
den Energiepreisen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und Herr Kollege jung ja Sie können
kritisieren überall und einige Punkte
auf die werde ich noch eingehen aber Sie
müssen auch hier sagen dass sie den
Ursprung die Grundlage für das alles
überhaupt nicht mitgetragen haben sie
haben gegen die 200 Milliarden gestimmt
die überhaupt die Voraussetzungen sind
dass wir das machen worum es hier heute
geht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich habe vor zwei Wochen einige Punkte
angesprochen die meiner Fraktion sehr
wichtig gewesen sind in den letzten 14
Tagen noch mal zu beraten und ich bin
froh dass wir diese Punkte jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren als
selbstbewusste Fraktionen auch geklärt
haben für uns war es richtig und wichtig
dass wir all die auch im Blick haben die
nicht nur von Gas oder von Fernwärme
abhängig sind sondern gerade die die Öl
und Pellets beziehen und ich weiß es ist
eine riesen Herausforderung weil wir
hier keine festen Versorgungsstrukturen
haben sondern auf Antragsverfahren
abstellen müssen aber dass die ähnlich
gestellt werden wie die gastron wo wir
sagen ja das Doppelte ist zu tragen aber
was darüber hinausgeht da helfen hilft
der Staat das ist eine Form von
Gerechtigkeit und ich erwarte das Bund
und Länder jetzt die Wege finden um hier
die Gerechtigkeit auch zu realisieren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und es ist richtig gewesen dass wir
beim Biogas und der Frage der
Abschöpfung auch noch mal nachjustiert
haben hier die Freibeträge angehoben
haben und kleine Anlagen rausnehmen aus
der
übergewinn-besteuerung dieses ist eine
Energieform die wir jetzt brauchen und
auch hier ist der parlamentarische
Eingriff dringend richtig und notwendig
gewesen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und dann bin ich bei Ihnen Herr
Kollege jung sie haben Recht wir werden
sehr genau aufpassen müssen dass das was
wir uns vorgenommen haben auch wirkt es
ist aber nicht die Bundesregierung
gewesen die beim
industrie-preis
interveniert hat sondern es sind
Vorgaben der Europäischen Kommission die
uns verpflichten bestimmte
Voraussetzungen einzuziehen und hier
sage ich ganz deutlich das werden wir
uns angucken an welchen Stellen wir hier
gegebenenfalls nachjustieren müssen das
ist ein lernendes Verfahren es gibt
keine Blaupause wir sind bereit
gegebenenfalls nachzusteuern wenn wir
mehr Punkte sehen wonach gesteuert
werden muss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wir werden uns garantiert nicht
zurücklehnen sondern Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister die Aufgaben
der nächsten Wochen sind klar skizziert
bei Kriseninterventionen darf es nicht
bleiben ich glaube es hat sie genauso
geschmerzt wie mich dass wir zum
Beispiel bei der Gewinnabschöpfung nicht
berücksichtigen konnte konnten wenn in
erneuerbare Energien investiert werden
konnte der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien analog zu dem was wir bei
lng-terminals jetzt schaffen muss der
Schlüssel sein dass wir dort maximal das
erreichen um Energie Souveränität
tatsächlich in diesem Land hinzubekommen
die Aufgaben liegen wieder vor uns sie
liegen nicht hinter uns und wir werden
uns als Sozialdemokratie dem mit voller
Kraft Stellen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
nach dem stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der SPD-Fraktion kommt jetzt Steffen
Portrait von der AFD zum Zug
in der Rede bzw mit der Rede zur
energiepreisbremse und dafür sind beide
Bremsen gemeint die gaspreisbremse wie
auch die strompreisbremse
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren das
Abrissunternehmen Ampelkoalition
marschiert weiter in Richtung Energie
und sozialpolitischen Abgrund und in den
Haushalt tierischen Wahnsinn die Summen
der transferzahlung sind nicht mehr real
gedeckt wir haben deshalb eine Inflation
von 10%, um mit dem daraus
resultierenden realen Schrumpfen der
nicht mehr rückzahlbaren Schulden den
Bürgern diesen Werteverlust
aufzuhalten wie ein Diktaturen werden
die selbst geschaffene Mangelwirtschaft
verwaltet und die Bürger geschöpft meine
Damen und Herren
planwirtschaftlich werden Löcher mit
Steuergeldern jetzt gestopft die wir in
einer funktionierenden sozialen
Marktwirtschaft ohne diese dumme und
naive Sanktionspolitik gar nicht hätten
trotz Preisbremse werden die überhöhten
Energiekosten ja doch bezahlt aber eben
jetzt wie auch schon bei der sogenannten
Energiewende von den Steuerzahlern die
Situation ließe sich sofort entschärfen
mit Kernenergie mit Kohleverstromung mit
Beendigung der nutzlosen Sanktionen aber
weil die Ampel das nicht tut müssen wir
konzentrieren dass wir hier mit einer
Veruntreuung von Steuergeldern haben zu
tun haben
die leider nicht mehr dem Volk
verpflichtete Ampel scheffelt das Geld
der deutschen über die eigentlichen
Energiekosten hinaus mit vollen Händen
ins Ausland in die USA für überteuertes
Flüssiggas nach Indien für russisches Öl
jetzt nach Frankreich und Belgien für
russisches
LNG und Russland bekommt trotzdem
weiterhin Geld obwohl die Propaganda der
Ampel genau das verhindern wollte mit
diesen Sanktionen aber das links grüne
Abbruchunternehmen Ampelkoalition macht
uns dadurch leider zu geißeln ihrer
heuchlerischen
moralpropaganda meine Damen und Herren
und normal
wäre eine Beendigung wenn Dinge nicht
funktionieren aber eben leider nicht bei
den Links Grünen die Veränderung der
niedrigen Strompreise muss also einen
Grund haben
und der liegt wohl in der Absicht uns
Deutsche finanziell zu schädigen unsere
Wirtschaftskraft quasi zu verdünnen wie
es wahrscheinlich der ehemalige grüne
Kriegsminister Joschka Fischer gesagt
hätte quasi zu verdünnen und ein
Instrument dafür ist es nicht direkt
preiswertes russisches Öl und Gas
einzukaufen sondern über Umwege und
Zwischenhändler und damit kann dann
diese trümmertruppe nämlich zusätzlich
Geld auseinander schaffen mit der
Einschaltung z.B das US-amerikanische
Unternehmens konoko Phillips für
katarisches Gas der belgischen fluxi der
französischen Totem energies
meine Damen und Herren mit einem
Straftatbestand Steuergeldverschwendung
säße vermutlich die gesamte
Bundesregierung auf der
Anklagebank die bröhe zahlen die Bürger
zahlen brach ihre hohen Steuern und die
Regierung verschwendet sie regelmäßig
das muss aufhören und deshalb wird es
mit der AFD diesen Straftatbestand
Steuergeldverschwendung geben
das
links grüne Politbüro löst mit seinen
planwirtschaftlichen
transferzahlung nicht nur nicht die
Probleme in unserem Land sondern sie
verschärft sie auch für die Zukunft die
preisdämpfung beim Kunden hier jetzt in
diesem Gesetzespaket bei uns vorliegend
kodifiziert löst nicht nur die Probleme
sondern sie bewirkt eine Anreiz für
unbegründete Preiserhöhung bei den
Unternehmen selbst bei den Lieferanten
im nächsten Jahr entfällt russisches
rohrleitungsgas komplett und der Ersatz
fehlt die bettelturm von Scholz und
Habeck waren bekanntlich nicht sehr
ergiebig und wenn die Weltwirtschaft
wieder anzieht ja dann wird überall in
den je nachgefragt und es wird für uns
auch knapper und teuer meine Damen und
Herren die Schädigung der Deutschland AG
geht leider weiter die Menschen in
unserem Land werden aber erkennen sich
wehren und dann ist es Schluss mit
dieser gegen unsere Menschen gerichtete
Politik
sie konnten sich natürlich nicht wieder
enthalten hier was zu sagen
es war tatsächlich das Ende der Rede von
Steffen Portrait von der AFD mit
historischen vergleichen und Ausflügen
in die deutsche Geschichte nächste
Redner Lukas Köhler von der FDP auch
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
zuständig für die Fragen von Strom und
gaspreisbremsen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben uns
vor nicht einmal zehn Monaten also noch
nicht mal vor einem Jahr hier darüber
unterhalten welche Auswirkungen dieser
Krieg hat und welche Auswirkungen dieser
Krieg haben und wir haben damals
festgestellt es wird nicht einfach und
natürlich ist es nicht einfach aber wir
haben auch damals schon sehr klar gesagt
alles was wir können werden wir hier in
diesem Hohen Haus mit der Ampel tun um
die Regierung zu unterstützen um gegen
diesen Krieg zu arbeiten um dafür zu
sorgen dass der Mittelstand erhalten
dass die Industrie erhalten dass wir
dafür sorgen dass Härten nicht so
treffen wie sie können wenn wir nichts
tun würden und wir haben immer gesagt
wir werden die Ukraine unterstützen und
das ist nach wie vor richtig es bleibt
richtig die Ukraine zu unterstützen auch
wenn es nicht einfach ist 200 Milliarden
neue Schulden aufzunehmen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir viel Geld an die
Menschen verteilen auch wenn es nicht
einfach ist dafür zu sorgen dass wir uns
zu sehen dass wir in eine neue Zeit
eintreten müssen wenn es um die
energieversorgnis und es ist trotzdem
richtig die Menschen zu unterstützen und
das ist trotzdem richtig dafür zu sorgen
dass die Ukraine unterstützt bleibt
wir haben mit der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse jetzt ein einfaches
schnelles und wirksames Instrument
vorgelegt ist es ein perfektes
Instrument nein wie sollen wir in so
kurzer Zeit das perfekte Gesetz machen
Wolfgang Schäuble hat es gerade gesagt
wir können in Schönheit sterben oder wir
können Dinge pragmatisch lösen und ich
finde es richtig dass wir uns für
Pragmatismus entschieden heißt das wir
werden alle wir werden kein Problem mit
diesem Gesetz bekommen nein das heißt es
nicht heißt es dass wir reaktionsfähig
sind ja das beweisen wir jeden Tag wir
beweisen und zeigen jedes Mal dass es
funktioniert dass wir Dinge besser
machen und ich finde es gut und richtig
dass wir in diesem Gesetz die
unterschiedlichen Anreize sind dass wir
dafür sorgen dass der Mittelstand
entlassen wird gut durch das Jahr kommt
dass wir für KMU ist noch mal ein
härtefallfonds auch lesen legen
gemeinsam mit den Ländern dass wir dafür
sorgen dass die Industrie wirklich bei
ihren Energiekosten unterstützt
und gleichzeitig müssen wir den Spar
Anreiz aufrechterhalten ich finde das
darf in dieser Debatte nicht vergessen
werden wenn wir zu wenig Gas sparen dann
reden wir in ein paar wenigen Monaten
nicht mehr über die Probleme eines
solchen Gesetzes oder die
Herausforderung vor der vegade steht
dann reden wir über eine gasmangelage
und das darf uns nicht passieren
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
schon und es ist auch richtig dass wir
diejenigen zum Beispiel die Erneuerbaren
die extreme Gewinne in diesem Jahr
eingefahren haben wegen dem Marktdesign
dass wir haben dass wir da dafür sorgen
dass die Zufalls Gewinne
und es ist trotzdem richtig dass wir
beim Biogas viel rausgeholt haben dafür
dass da die Härten nicht kommen dass wir
dafür gesorgt haben dass wir weiterhin
flexible Leistungen am Markt haben denn
auf der einen Seite sparen ist richtig
aber auf der anderen Seite müssen wir
heute schon in die Zukunft denken wir
müssen heute darüber nachdenken woher
kommt das Gas in der Zukunft und ja da
darf auch die deutsche Gasförderung
nicht ausgeschlossen sein aber es darf
natürlich nicht dabei enden wir müssen
in der Erneuerbare Energien investieren
wir müssen aber auch ein neues Strom
aktiv sein Schaffen wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die Industrie dass der
Mittelstand dass die Wirtschaft dass die
Menschen in diesem Land mit günstiger
Energie versorgt werden wenn wir das
alles hinbekommen dann sind wir auf
einem wirklich guten Weg zum Schluss
möchte ich noch mal Robert Habeck und
dem bmwk für dieses Gesetz danke
ich glaube wir haben hier wirklich
selbst vorgelegt vielen Dank
soweit Lukas Köhler von der FDP dem Dank
an Robert Herbig wird sich sicherlich
der nächste Redner nicht anschließen
Klaus Ernst von der Fraktion die Linken
erst auch gleichzeitig Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
federführend für das Gesetzesvorhaben
so meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
verlangen sie haben gerade gesagt das
war bei uns eigentlich nie billig
der erste grandiose Fehlschluss den sie
da machen
der niedrige Gaspreis war mit
Ursache dieses Wohlstands dieser
Republik in den letzten 50 Jahren und zu
diesem und von diesem Wohlstand haben
auch sie profitiert sie konnten
studieren
der industriell die industrielle Basis
beruht zum einen auf der Energie und zum
anderen auf den gut ausgebildeten Leuten
auch vernünftigen Löhnen das heute in
Frage zu stellen und zu tun als wäre es
nicht gewesen die schlichtig an der
Realität vollkommen vorbei und ich freue
mich übrigens dass ich unsere
exkanzlerin tatsächlich weigert sich für
diese Politik zu entschuldigen ne das
sage ich ihnen weil ist sie freuen sich
darüber dass ich nicht und oder
irgendwie das ist nicht tot ich finde es
gut dass sie das nicht tut dass sie zu
diesem Punkt sich bekennt ich würde mich
freuen von der CDU würden es mehr sehen
zweitens wir machen jetzt ein
gaspreisdeckel
also ein gaspreisbremse ich weiß nicht
ob ihnen verdoppeln trotz dieses trotz
dieses dieser Bremse verdoppeln wir den
Gaspreis für 80% des Gases wird
80% des Gases ist doch schlichtweg
doppelt so teuer wie vorher
80%, und den Rest und den Rest dem Köpfe
den Rest machen wir überhaupt nichts der
der das ist der Rest ist Marktpreis wir
verdoppeln die Energiepreise beim Gas
und beim Strom 35 %. das ist die
Realität ihres denken ich weiß nicht
warum sie sich so aufregen lassen Sie
doch ihr eigenes Gesetz Unterstützung
drin und dann sage ich Ihnen das führt
eben nicht dazu das würde mir Ergebnis
nicht dazu dass eigentlich das passieren
sollte was die Bundesregierung mit den
Amtszeit versprochen hat nämlich Schaden
vom deutschen Volk abzuwenden ist kein
Schaden ist dann weiß ich nicht noch was
der Schaden ist meine Damen und Herren
und ich sage Ihnen auch dass und ich
sage Ihnen auch das aus diesem Gründen
das aus diesen Gründen wir keine
gasbremse machen sondern mit ihrer
Politik wird dazu beitragen dass
insbesondere die industrielle Basis
dieses Landes gefährdet wird ich danke
Ihnen für die Aufmerksamkeit
ja für jeden und jede noch mal zu
mitschreiben im Gesetz steht die ersten
80% des bisherigen Verbrauchs mit 12
Cent pro Kilowattstunde beim
Gasverbrauch und 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde beim Stromverbrauch für
die Privathaushalte ich sage es noch
einmal die ersten 80% des bisherigen
Vertrauen Verbrauchs nächste Redner
Andreas an autress von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
frau Präsidentin
Herr Ernst ich muss mit ihnen anfangen
es ist traurig und ich hätte das gerne
anders gemacht aber es ist einfach nicht
möglich daran vorbeizugehen was sie
gerade gesagt haben sie sind Vorsitzende
des Ausschusses für Klima und Energie
und wenn Sie hier sprechen kriegen sie
Applaus ausschließlich aus einer
Fraktion nämlich von ganz rechts von der
AFD ich weiß nicht wohin sich die Linke
entwickeln will aber das was wir hier
erlebt haben sein weiterer Tiefpunkt und
ist traurig es tut mir leid
wir decken
wir Deckeln heute Gas und Strompreise
für Millionen von Menschen für Millionen
von Unternehmen für Krankenhäuser
Schulen Kitas Kultureinrichtungen
soziale Einrichtungen und das ist ein
Handeln in einer Dimension die so in
Deutschland noch nie da gewesen ist eine
klare Ansage dass wir uns nicht
erpressen lassen dass wir uns nicht
erpressen lassen mit Energie als Waffe
und dass wir uns schon gar nicht
erpressen lassen von einem Diktator
namens Wladimir Putin und ich sage Ihnen
mal was das in der Praxis bedeutet zum
Beispiel für eine vierköpfige Familie
100 Quadratmeter Wohnfläche diese
Familie spart durch die Deckelungen bei
Gas und Strom über
1500 € im Jahr das ist die Antwort die
wir geben auf Wladimir Putin auch an die
hier im Deutschen Bundestag die
versuchen diese die Menschen in so einer
schwierigen Lage aufzuwiegen und vor
allem ist es die Antwort die wir geben
an all die Menschen da draußen irgendwie
verdient haben dass wir in dieser Krise
solidarisch sind und Probleme gelöst
kriegen
Fairness und Gerechtigkeit das hat uns
bei der Ausgestaltung der Bremsen
geleitet und deswegen ist es ein Gebot
der Vernunft dass diese Maßnahmen dass
die Bremsen versteuert werden weil die
die mehr haben die können natürlich auch
etwas mehr beitragen die Menschen die
sehr wenig haben die brauchen jetzt den
vollen Entlastungsbetrag und deswegen
haben wir eingeführt dass die Bremsen
versteuert werden und schaffen so ein
Prinzip von Gerechtigkeit und
Solidarität auch in dieser Krise
und das gilt selbstverständlich auch für
Vorstände für die Manager von
Unternehmen die nun hohe
Millionenbeträge an Unterstützung
kriegen können und ich sage es einmal
sehr sehr klar Staatshilfen in dieser
Krise sind richtig und sie sind
notwendig und gleichzeitig muss dabei
aber doch klar sein dass diese Hilfen in
die Betriebe fließen müssen dass diese
Investitionen in die Unternehmen in die
Zukunft fließen müssen in den Standort
Deutschland wir subventionieren nicht
die konnten von
Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden oder
Vorstandsvorsitzenden wir wollen nicht
dass Dividenden dann ausgezahlt werden
wenn hohe Millionenbeträge vom
Steuerzahler an die Unternehmen geht das
was wir tun ist Zukunft zu finanzieren
das was wir tun ist zu stützen um daraus
für Unternehmen eine Perspektive zu
erreichen und das ist das was wir mit
dieser Preis Bremse umsetzen können
eines darf uns bei all dieser aktuellen
Lage nicht passieren wir dürfen bei der
Bewältigung der Probleme nicht die
größte Krise unserer Zeit die Klimakrise
aus den Augen verlieren und darum ist
Nachhaltigkeit und darum ist
Klimaneutralität genau die Perspektive
die wir brauchen um aus dieser Krise
wieder herauszukommen und deswegen haben
wir in den Verhandlungen dafür gesorgt
dass die mögliche Förderung für
erneuerbare bei den Ausschreibungen um
25% angehoben wird weil wir wissen dass
wir jetzt einen massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien brauchen um die
Krise zu überwinden raus aus Putins Gas
und raus aus Putins Öl muss heißen rein
in die Erneuerbaren und auch das machen
wir mit diesen Paket und auch das ist
Teil der Lösung die wir hier heute
vorlegen
wir investieren in Solidarität und
Fairness in dieser Krise und
gleichzeitig investieren wir in
Nachhaltigkeit und klimatalität um mit
Deutschland aus dieser Krise schnell und
nachhaltig wieder herauszukommen
dankeschön
Andreas outrecht von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen mit seinem Debattenbeitrag
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
bei Bündnis 90 Sekunden diese Funktion
hat auch hier in Spahn in der frühere
Bundesgesundheitsminister in der cdu/csu
und Kollegen wir haben gestern gehört
unter anderem von Frau dröge Herr dürr
sie wünschen sich eine konstruktive
Opposition und die kriegen sie seit
Monaten die Union als Konstruktion als
konstruktive Opposition hat seit März
die Union hat seit März die wirksamste
aller Preis Bremsen gefordert eine
Ausweitung des Angebots umso mehr Strom
produziert wird desto niedriger der
Preis sie haben den Menschen monatelang
erzählt morgens im Radio abends in der
Tagesschau wir hätten keinen Strom
Problem sie haben erst gelacht als wir
gesagt haben mehr Kohle ans Netz sie
haben unsere Anträge für mehr Biogas und
Windenergie abgelehnt sie haben sich bei
der Kernenergie unseren Vorschlägen
psychologisch verweigert aktuell
übrigens Frau lang wird fast zwei
Drittel unsere Stroms wochenweise aus
fossilen Brennstoffen Kohle und Gas
produziert wie stellen Sie sich das
eigentlich vor wenn dann die drei
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden für
nächsten Winter dass wir noch mehr Gas
verbrennen lassen Sie die drei
Kernkraftwerke in dieser Krise in den
nächsten zwei Wintern am Netz
die Union als konstruktive Opposition
sagt ihnen seit dem Sommer dass sie
Haushalte und Wirtschaft schnell und
wirksam entlasten sollten schnell durch
eine Senkung der Mehrwert und
Energiesteuern das haben sie bisher nur
beim Gas gemacht das sollte jetzt auch
vor allem beim Öl passieren und
Millionen Haushalte zu entlasten sie
machen es nicht schnell und wirksam für
diejenigen das sind Millionen Haushalte
in Deutschland die mit Öl heizen vor
allem in ländlichen Raum sie machen
irgendeinen vor von dem bis heute keiner
weiß ob überhaupt irgendwo eine Hilfe
ankommt sie machen Millionen Haushalte
zu Antragstellern
bürokratisch und einfach zu machen sie
haben stattdessen
sie haben das stattdessen monatelang
Zeit mit einer gasumlage vergeudet die
in der Krise den Preis noch erhöht hätte
dann haben sie eine gaskommission
eingesetzt spät aber immerhin die
Ergebnisse haben sie zelebriert und nun
setzen Sie die Ergebnisse der Kommission
so um das weite Teile der Wirtschaft sie
gar nicht werden in Anspruch nehmen
können oder wollen dass sie entlasten
wollen ist richtig und ja das haben wir
immer gefordert aber sie machen es
bürokratisch halbherzig spät und
hektisch der BDI-Präsident Russwurm der
Mitglied der gaskommission war sagte
gestern er wäre tief enttäuscht die
Politik lege mit ihrer Ignoranz
gegenüber den betrieblichen Realitäten
die Axt an die Grundpfeiler des
Standortes Deutschland
verbraucherschützer sind enttäuscht die
Gewerkschaften alarmiert eine
konstruktive Opposition kann solchen
Befunden nicht zustimmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wer wer eine konstruktive Opposition
will Herr Kollege gremmels der sollte
sie einbinden sie haben in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten trotz mehrfacher
Angebote nicht dass ernsthafte Gespräch
mit uns gesucht sie haben uns im
Gegenteil Dienstagnacht über 400
seitenänderungsanträge geschickt die
Mittwochmorgen im Ausschuss beschlossen
werden sollten im Ausschuss konnten sie
teilweise selbst ihre Regelungen für Öl
und Pellets zum Beispiel nicht wirklich
nachvollziehbar erläutern der ich war
digital zugeschaltet Herr Kollege Kruse
das Schöne das schöne an hybridensitzung
ist man kann digital teilnehmen und
dabei habe ich gemerkt Herr Kollege
Kruse der zuständige Energieminister war
im energieausschuss einmal mehr nicht da
und er Habeck es ist schon bezeichnet
dass heute hier in dieser Debatte bei
diesem Thema sie nicht reden wer von
seinem eigenen Gesetz überzeugt ist der
kann es auch hier vom Deutschen
Bundestag vertreten und muss sich den
Gesundheitsminister schicken um die
Energiepolitik der Regierung zu erklären
Liebe Kolleg und Kollegen
statt die konstruktive Opposition zu
beschimpfen statt dieses teilweise
aggressive mimimi dass wir gestern vor
allem in der Debatte erlebt haben
sollten Sie lieber schauen wie wir zu
einer konstruktiven Regierung kommt wie
wir es schaffen ja in einem guten
Gespräch und Sie können das für sich
entscheiden sie können für sich
entscheiden sie haben die Mehrheit sie
ziehen das hier durch das ist völlig
okay sehr gutes Recht aber erwarten Sie
dann nicht dass wir da ein Mithaftung
gehen denn die einzige Bremse die seit
Monaten wirklich wirkt ist leider die
Ampel selbst sie bremsen mehr Angebot
beim Strom und damit niedrige Preise
politisch aus sie bremsen wirklich
wirksame Hilfen für Handwerk Mittelstand
und Industrie und damit für Millionen
Arbeitsplätze aus sie bremsen ein
ordentliches parlamentarisches Verfahren
eine gute Debatte und notwendige
Transparenz aus das Ergebnis ist ein
Gesetz das gut gemeint ist aber nicht
gut gemacht so viel Halbherzigkeit
Bürokratie und Hektik dafür sollten Sie
uns nicht in Verantwortung nehmen wollen
die müssen sie schon selber tragen eine
konstruktive Opposition kann da nicht
zustimmen
soweit Jens Spahn jetzt wird sicherlich
die Gegenrede dazu kommen Verena
hupperts stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der
SPD-Fraktion ebenso wie in Spanien und
in der Unionsfraktion wird sich jetzt
zum Thema energiepreisbremsen äußern
Frau Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen was ein ja heute in der letzten
Sitzungswoche des Deutschen Bundestages
beschließen wir ein noch nie dagewesenes
Paket mit Bremsen Gas und Strom so dass
die Wirtschaft aber auch die Haushalte
in diesem Land gut durch diese Krise
kommen und da würde ich mir wünschen
Herr Spahn wenn sie da dann auch mal
zustimmen und nicht dagegen sind denn
bei ihren vorschlägenständen welche
schon wo ganz anders und deswegen ist
das heute ein wichtiger Schritt für
dieses Parlament
und ich möchte hier heute mal auf die
wirtschaftspolitischen Themen eingehen
denn wir erinnern uns noch alle an den
Sommer an die Bäckereien die gesagt
haben ich bekomme ja keine Hilfe weil
ich nicht auf irgendeiner Liste stehe
die kübelliste heißt und weil die Hilfen
nicht für mich greifen und das was wir
jetzt tun das sind unternehmenshilfen
die helfen den großen
Aktiengesellschaften den kleinen
Personengesellschaften egal in welcher
Branche egal wo wir ziehen eine Bremse
ein damit wir in diesem Land noch was zu
transformieren haben nach dieser Krise
und das ist wichtig
aber wir stellen auch Bedingungen an
diese Unterstützungen
zum Beispiel wenn Unternehmen ganz ganz
viele und ganz große Millionenhilfen
bekommen dann erwarten wir auch dass der
Standort gesichert bleibt und die
Arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben und dass
man nicht den Koffer mit dem Geld nimmt
und dann woanders das Werk wieder
aufbaut und dafür haben wir uns als
Sozialdemokratie stark gemacht
und es geht auch um Respekt in diesem
Land
das Unternehmen auch ihren Beitrag
leisten dass wir alle gemeinsam gut
durch diese Krise kommen und da kann es
nicht sein wenn ich auf der einen Seite
Steuergelder und ganz viel Staatshilfe
bekomme auf der anderen Seite sage so
jetzt schütte ich doch mal hier die
Gewinne aus und ich erhöh doch mal den
Boni und bevor ich dieses Mandat letztes
Jahr angenommen habe war ich selbst
Unternehmerin in der corona-pandemie war
es für uns alle eine schwierige Zeit und
da bin ich nicht hingegangen und habe
mein Gehalt erhöht da habe ich das
Gehalt gekürzt und nicht noch ein Bonus
ausgeschüttet und deswegen haben wir
auch verboten in diesem Gesetz verankert
und das ist auch ein Zeichen des
gemeinsamen Respekts ein Zeichen dass
wir auch gemeinsam unseren Beitrag
leisten müssen
und natürlich sind in diesem Gesetz
viele Berechnungsgrundlagen drin zum
Beispiel das
vorjahreszeiträume bestimmen welcher
Grundbedarf denn zum Beispiel
subventioniert wird und 2021 war für uns
alle kein einfaches Jahr und 2021 fließt
mit rein in diese Berechnung für die
Hotellerie Gastronomie den Einzelhandel
wir hatten staatlich verordnete
lockdowns wir hatten aber auch ich bin
Rheinland-Pfälzerinnen eine
Flutkatastrophe die nicht nur unser
Bundesland sondern auch
Nordrhein-Westfalen und Bayern betroffen
hat und wenn an der einen Seite das
Betriebswerk wegschwemmt oder das
Restaurant nicht öffnen kann da kann ich
nicht sagen 21 war die
Berechnungsgrundlage und das nehmen wir
jetzt und darauf berechnen wir eben die
Hilfen nein wer einmal im Regen
gestanden hat darf nicht ein zweites Mal
im Regen stehen und deswegen werden dort
individuelle Prognosen angelegt und das
haben wir im parlamentarischen Verfahren
jetzt auch noch mal klargestellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja das
ist ein dickes Brett und das ist auch
nicht perfekt und der Kollege Mirsch hat
eben schon darauf hingewiesen wir werden
auch noch mal unsere Hausaufgaben
mitnehmen nach Brüssel damit wir schauen
da wo das temporary crisis Framework
also dieses rahmenkorsett was überhaupt
erlaubt was unternehmen auch jetzt an
Hilfe bekommen können dass da wo zum
Beispiel die großen Konzerne die ein
Gewinnrückgang zum Beispiel zeigen
müssen ein ewitter-rückgang ja das passt
noch nicht so richtig gut zusammen und
deswegen wird der Wirtschaftsminister
deswegen wird der Kanzler und wir alle
gemeinsam dafür in Brüssel werden dass
das was wir hier auch bereitstellen auch
ankommt und da lade ich Sie herzlich ein
dann doch bitte heute mal zuzustimmen
und nicht nur zu sagen was wäre denn
heute ist erstmal ein wichtiger Tag für
die Menschen und die Wirtschaft in
diesem Land damit wir da alle
miteinander gut rauskommen vielen
herzlichen Dank
voraussichtlich nächster Redner ist Marc
Bernhard von der AFD er Sprecher für
Bauen und Wohnen und ist auch Mitglied
im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
die AFD wird am Ende dieser Debatte auch
einen Entschließungsantrag und einen
Änderungsantrag zur
strompreisbremse einbringen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das Konzept ihrer Energiewende wahres
alle Kohle und Kernkraftwerke
abzuschalten und diese durch
Gaskraftwerke zu ersetzen die hier
überall im Land gebaut werden sollten
so wurden allein Anfang diesen Jahres 10
Gigawatt Leistungen Kern und
Kohlekraftwerken abgeschaltet das ist
genauso wie wenn man ganz
Baden-Württemberg den Stecker ziehen
würde seitdem Beginn des um keine Kriegs
ist die aber jedem klar dass dieser Plan
so nicht mehr funktionieren wird und es
ist jetzt 10 Monate her und was haben
Sie von der Regierung in diesen zehn
Monaten gemacht und die
Energieversorgung unseres Landes
sicherzustellen ganz offensichtlich
nicht sinnvolles denn sonst müssten die
Bürger heute nicht in doppelten
Strompreis und in fünf Jahren Gaspreis
bezahlen sie hätten sofort mit
Kriegsbeginn handeln müssen denn
Ausstieg aus Kohle und Kernenergie
aussetzen und alle nur wenige Wochen
vorher vom Netz genommenen Kraftwerke
wieder ins Netz nehmen und dann hätten
wir diese ganze Energie Katastrophe hier
heute nämlich gar nicht
die haben also diese aktuellen Notlage
sei es mutwillig oder durch Unfähigkeit
sehenden Auges herbeigeführt und deshalb
muss den Menschen jetzt auch dringend
geholfen werden denn in Deutschland darf
niemand frieren aber was sie hier machen
was sie hier machen ist eine reine
Symptombekämpfung die am grundsätzlichen
Problem überhaupt gar nichts ändert von
ihren so von ihren sogenannten 200
Milliarden Euro Abwehr Schirm kostet
allein die Strom und gaspreisbremse 100
Milliarden wie viele Winter sollen in
die Bürger diese 100 Milliarden für den
Strom und Gaspreis Deckel bezahlen frage
ich Sie das ist doch nichts anderes als
eine reine Steuer Verbrennungsmaschine
die Menschen müssen nämlich immer noch
für 80% ihr Verbrauchs den dreifachen
Gaspreis wie im letzten Jahr bezahlen
und für den Rest in unbegrenzter Höhe
die restlichen 20 Prozent unbegrenzt
nach oben was wie hier brauchen ist eine
dauerhafte und nachhaltige Lösung
nämlich ganz einfach das zu tun wogegen
sich diese Regierung seit zehn Monaten
rigoros weigert nämlich alle verfügbaren
Kern und Kohlekraftwerke wieder ins Netz
zu nehmen oder weiterlaufen zu lassen
eigene Gasvorkommen nutzen und vor allem
vor allem nicht aus teuren Gas Strom zu
erzeugen und diesen dann in riesigen
Mengen ins Ausland zu exportieren
helfen sie den Menschen wirklich bringen
sie die 2021 abgeschalteten Kraftwerke
wieder ins Netz und der Strompreis
halbiert sich von heute auf morgen von
ganz alleine
[Applaus]
soweit mag Bernhard von der
afd-fraktion
nächster Redner laut Rednerliste ist
jetzt Michael Kruse von der FDP er ist
der energiepolitische Sprecher der
Parteien
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin
Volkswirt und ich bin Freidemokrat und
Preisbremse und gewinnabschöpfungen sind
exakt das Gegenteil davon wofür ich mich
dafür habe in dieses Parlament wählen
lassen sie sind nicht treffsicher und
sie schaffen auch nicht die richtigen
Anreize nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass
Menschen bei stark steigenden
Energiepreisen auch die richtigen
Anpassungen vornehmen und sich an die
hohen Preise eben anpassen deshalb ist
für mich vollkommen klar diese
Instrumente dürfen nur in einer Notlage
wie der aktuellen eingesetzt werden und
Sie müssen wieder enden sobald dies
möglich ist nur der russische
energiekrieg gegen Deutschland
rechtfertigt einen Einsatz ein
temporären Einsatz derartiger
Instrumente
[Applaus]
und lieber Herr Kollege Spahn ich
wundere mich etwas über ihren partiellen
Gedächtnisverlust ich weiß dass die
corona-gesetzgebung in den letzten
Jahren unter Eder ihrer Federführung
teilt so hektisch war dass die
Änderungen noch im Ausschuss vorgetragen
worden sind und deswegen fände ich es
ehrlich gesagt für eine
verantwortungsvolle
Opposition angemessen das Gesetz dass
wir hier vorliegen an seiner Qualität zu
bemessen und nicht daran wie das
Verfahren nun gelaufen ist sie wissen
dass wir sehr schnelle Gesetze machen
beurteilen Sie die Qualität und stimmen
Sie danach ab dann müssen sie diesem
Gesetz nämlich heute zustimmen
die Verunsicherung in ihnen
Energiemärkten ist groß sie hat zu
starken Preisanstiegen geführt und
dieser externe Stock bedroht die
Volkswirtschaft und er bedroht auch
viele Menschen in Deutschland in ihrer
wirtschaftlichen Existenz das ist der
Grund warum wir derartige Eingriffe
vornehmen wir entlasten mit diesem
Instrument in einem Ausmaß wie ist das
in der Geschichte Deutschlands meines
Wissens nach noch nicht gegeben hat die
Ampel ist damit die
entlastungskoalition in Deutschland und
dass wir Freie Demokraten besonders viel
Wert auf die Entlastung der Menschen
legen das brauche ich glaube ich an
dieser Stelle nicht zu betonen Herr
Kruse gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage
oder Bemerkung aus der AFD Fraktion
Carsten hilze von der afd-fraktion mit
einer Zwischenfrage vielen Dank Herr
Kruse dass Sie Herr Kollege dass sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen sie haben ja
gerade schon erwähnt dass sie also gegen
ihre eigene Überzeugung eigentlich
Überzeugung diesem Gesetz hier zustimmen
also dieses mittragen und wir hatten ja
gestern Ausschuss und dort
ja gab es eine absurde Schauspiel Herr
Ernst der Ausschussvorsitzender hat
richtigerweise
gesagt dass laut Geschäftsordnung der
Ausschuss nur dann Beschlussempfehlungen
abgeben darf wenn das wenn es ein
sachlichen Zusammenhang zwischen
verschiedenen Dingen in diesem Gesetz
gibt und sie wissen ja jetzt das ist ein
Omnibus Gesetz ist wo also das
Infektionsschutzgesetz geändert wird
dass also Apotheken also impfen dürfen
das durften sie schon vorher aber eben
erleichtert jetzt würde ich von Ihnen
gerne den sachlichen Zusammenhang
zwischen den impfen in Apotheken und der
gaspreisbremse
erklärt bekommen das wäre sehr nett
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
also erste Bemerkung dazu
es schließt sich also der Kreis zu der
Rede des Vorsitzenden Ernst bei dem
wieder Kollege von den Grünen
festgestellt hat ja ausschließlich die
afd-fraktion geklatscht hat ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht wohin das ganze
hier noch führen sollen erstens zweitens
wenn ich es im spaßen beantworten wollte
würde ich einfach sagen es wird ja einen
Grund geben warum der
Bundesgesundheitsminister gleich noch
spricht und auch der ehemalige
Gesundheitsminister hat ja hier die
Themen Gesundheit und Energie auf eine
ganz interessante Art und Weise
verknüpft nämlich im Verfahren aber ich
möchte Ihnen auch einfach sagen dass das
was wir hier im Moment machen eben
krisengesetzgebung ist dass sie diese
Krise in den letzten zehn Monaten
wollt fast sagen ausgeblendet haben aber
ausgeblendet stimmt ja gar nicht denn
sie hatten ja eine Veranstaltung und
Herr Kollege sie waren auf dieser
Veranstaltung anwesend sie saßen sogar
ganz nah am Mikrofon sie hatten eine
Veranstaltung in diesem Sommer wo sie
darauf gehofft haben dass dieser Winter
eine Katastrophe wird damit Ihnen die
Wählerinnen und Wähler zulaufen und dass
das nicht passiert ist zeigt wir machen
hier genau das Richtige wir sorgen dafür
dass Schaden vom deutschen Volk
abgewendet ist das tun wir im Bereich
der corona-politik und das tun wir im
Bereich der Energiepolitik es ist
bedauerlich es ist eine Schande dass sie
nicht in der Lage sind auch konstruktiv
an diesem Thema mitzuarbeiten und
deswegen werden wir auch weiterhin alles
tun um dieses Land vor Schaden zu
bewahren sie freuen sich in Wahrheit
darüber wenn die Energiespeicher leer
sind sie freuen sich das Putin kein Gas
mehr in Deutschland liefern weil sie
ausschließlich auf ihr eigenes
Punktekonto schaut
machen wir nicht mit wir sind vom
deutschen Volk für das deutsche Volk
gewählt worden meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren Herr Kruse
ich habe eine weitere Zwischenfrage oder
mehr Bemerkung vom Kollegen Ernst aus
der Fraktion DIE LINKE ja gerne also
nach der Intervention von rechts jetzt
auch noch von links Klaus Ernst wurde ja
auch in der Rede von Michael Kruse
angesprochen Klaus Ernst von den Linken
war es auch angesprochen worden ist das
selbst in einem schiffstück des
Ministeriums der Vermerk darauf stand
Vorsicht sachfremd also das Verfahren
des wir gestern hatten in diesem
Ausschuss möchte das noch mal eindeutig
sagen war auch als meiner Sicht nicht in
Ordnung
wir haben eine Fülle von Vorschlägen
bekommen von ihnen zu einem Zeitpunkt wo
es keinem Abgeordneten mehr möglich war
rechtzeitig und einigermaßen sauber
überhaupt zu lesen was sie vorschlagen
selbst über die ganze Nacht
durchgewiesen hätten das ja nach 12 Uhr
eingegangen nach 12 Uhr nachts
eingegangen also ich weiß nicht was sie
daran eigentlich zu verteidigen sie
haben sich in dem Ausschuss entschuldigt
für dieses Verfahren
es wäre angebracht ist auch hier zu tun
und nicht die zu kritisieren die einen
solchen ein solches Verfahren nicht mehr
akzeptieren ich hoffe Herr Kruse das
nicht unternehmen
die letztendlich nicht mit einverstanden
sind dass sie jetzt Gewinne abgeschöpft
Kriegen gegen dieses Gesetz deshalb
klagen weil sie sagen es ist nicht
ordnungsgemäß zustande gekommen wenn das
nämlich wäre dann hätten sie sozusagen
ihr Ziel erreicht sie sagen ja sie sind
im Gesetz eigentlich sowieso nicht
einverstanden aber deshalb wäre es
vielleicht sinnvoller künftig darauf zu
achten dass die Verfahren eingehalten
werden
[Applaus]
Ausschusses um den es hier gegen der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
was da gestern besprochen worden ist im
Vorfeld der heutigen Gesetze
gesetzesentscheidung im Parlament
vorlegen sie ausgiebig die Gelegenheit
hatten sich mit dem Inhalt dieser
Gesetze zu beschäftigen wir dann noch
wir dann noch als Koalition viele
Verbesserungen an diesem Gesetz
vorgenommen haben und ich glaube dass
sich die Menschen in diesem Land vor
allem dafür interessieren was wir mit
den 230 Milliarden die wir hier heute
beschließen werden denn eigentlich
Unternehmen und ich hätte mich sehr
gefreut wenn sich ihre Debattenbeiträge
auch darauf beziehen würden wie denn
dieses Geld verwendet wird wie es
richtig eingesetzt wird wie es Schaden
von den Menschen abhält wie es Schaden
von den Unternehmen in diesem Land
abhält wie wir vielleicht Dinge von
denen wir wissen dass sie noch nicht
optimal sind wie wir die verbessern ich
nenne ihn mal ein Beispiel der haben
erkannt dass es Missbrauchs Potenzial in
diesem Gesetz gibt wir haben erkannt
die Möglichkeit gibt hier auch gegen den
Steuerzahler sich zu optimieren das ist
der Grund warum es in diesem Gesetz eine
zusätzliche Verordnung gibt meine
Erwartung an den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist da ganz
klar er muss dafür sorgen dass diese
Verordnung jetzt auch sehr schnell kommt
und dass das Missbrauchspotenzial
bestmöglich eingedämmt wird wollen wir
vielleicht darüber reden wie 230
Milliarden die den Menschen in diesem
Land gehört richtig eingesetzt werden
und nicht über die Frage wann Sie eine
E-Mail bekommen haben oder wann Sie eine
E-Mail bekommen haben das ist dermaßen
selbstreferenziell dass es dem Anspruch
des Hohen Hauses hier nicht gerecht wird
meine Damen und Herren
und ich meine das ist der wesentliche
Punkt zum einen wir haben noch eine
ganze Menge zu tun und wir laden die
Opposition dazu ein an diesen Stellen
auch weiter mitzuarbeiten das Thema
Missbrauchspotential ich habe es eben
angesprochen und ich werde auch selbst
ganz persönlich weiterhin auch
öffentlich dafür werben dass wir diese
Lücken schließen denn es sind noch große
Lücken und das zweite ist die Zeit des
kühlen der künstliche günstigsten
Energie sie muss bestmöglich genutzt
werden erstens für die dauerhafte
Erhöhung des energieangebots wir müssen
eine ehrliche Kapazitätsplanung
vornehmen dazu gehört für uns für eine
Industrienation wie Deutschland auch die
Ausweitung günstiger CO2 freier
Grundlastkraftwerke der Ausbau der
heimischen Gasförderung und
selbstverständlich auch der Ausbau der
freiheitsenergie und natürlich gehört
dazu auch dass wir beim Thema Effizienz
jetzt mal PS machen was ist denn
eigentlich mit den Smart Mietern in den
letzten 10 Jahren geschehen da ist unter
den großen Koalition gar nichts
vorangekommen wir haben große Aufgaben
für das Jahr 2023 die erste Welle der
Attacken aus Russland haben wir
abgeschmettert aber die Deiche müssen
dauerhaft gestärkt werden bei uns im
Norden heißt es nicht der Wind
entscheidet den Kurs sondern das
richtige Setzen der Segel und das wird
für 2023 unsere Aufgabe sein in allen
frohe Weihnachten und herzlichen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
Michael Kruse von der FDP dessen
Redezeit sich etwas verlängert hat durch
die beiden Zwischenfragen von Carsten
[Applaus]
Carsten Ilse von der
afd-fraktion und Klaus Ernst von den
Linken Redner jetzt Ralf lenkert
ebenfalls von der Fraktion der Linken
auch in diesen Zeiten müssen Strom und
Gas bezahlbar bleiben deshalb ist ein
preiswertes grundkontingent für Strom
und Gas nach Haushaltsgröße notwendig
bei Strom kostet die Kilowattstunde
maximal 30 bei Gas maximal 18 und wir
brauchen eine monatliche
inflationspauschale von 75 € je Haushalt
plus 50 € je Person im Haushalt vom
Staat bezahlt
das fordert DIE LINKE das wäre ein guter
Weg durch den Winter jetzt hat die Ampel
Einmalzahlung von nur 300 Euro
veranlasst hat eine Preisgrenze von 40
sind bei Strom und 12 sind bei Gas
festgeschrieben aber nur für 80 Prozent
des bisherigen persönlichen Verbrauches
das reicht nicht wer viel verdient viel
Strom und gasverbraucht hat die Mitte
leicht 20% Energie einzusparen und
bekommt dafür dann die Gesamtenergie zum
Festpreis arme Familien dagegen mussten
schon immer Energie sparen und haben
heute mehr denn je nicht das Geld
sparsame Technik zu kaufen die müssen
dann mehr zahlen das ist unsozial
schamlos nutzen Konzerne und Spekulanten
jede Gelegenheit Preise und Profite
hochzutreiben RWE machte allein im
ersten Halbjahr den zweieinhalbfachen
Gewinn des kompletten Vorjahres Shell
steigerte den halbjahresgewinn von 5,5
auf 12 Milliarden Euro über 50
Milliarden Euro sondergewinne vielen in
Deutschland bis heute an diese Gewinne
will die Linke abschöpfen für die
Finanzierung erhilfen für Bürgerinnen
und Bürger für produzierende Unternehmen
für Handwerk für Hochschulen und für
Krankenhäuser aber diese Ampel schöpft
nur kümmerliche 3 Milliarden ab bei 50
Milliarden extra-
Strom gaswärme sind unverzichtbare
Daseinsvorsorge Daseinsvorsorge muss der
Gesellschaft gehören das fordert DIE
LINKE vielen Dank
soweit Ralf lenkert von den Linken
nächste Rednerinnen ist Ingrid Nestle
von bis 90 die Grünen es geht noch etwa
bis 11 Uhr Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer
mit dieser Debatte zu den beiden
energiepreisbremsen weiter danach gibt
es zwei namentliche Abstimmungen also
gegen 11 Uhr etwa ist diese Debatte
beendet sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir unterstützen heute mit diesem Gesetz
alle in diesem Land die von den
dramatischen Preissteigerungen von
fossilem Erdgas getroffen sind sei es
direkt oder indirekt durch die
Preissteigerungen bei Strom und Wärme
wir unterstützen alle egal ob Haushalt
ob Unternehmen ob Kommunen weil wir
einen gemeinsamen Ansatz haben bei dem
niemand durch die Lücke fällt durch die
Ritze zu definieren was ist das
Unternehmen im Hinterzimmer der Wohnung
wir unterstützen alle und das ist gut so
das Geld
das Geld kommt auch bei den Menschen an
ohne dass sie einen Antrag stellen
müssen ohne ein einziges Formular an
auszufüllen kommt diese substanzielle
und entscheidende Hilfe bei den Menschen
an und auch das ist gut so
wichtig ist auch dass die Menschen nicht
nur direkt Geld bekommen mit diesem
Gesetz sondern wenn sie Energie sparen
und da danke ich auch der Union die das
auch angesprochen hat ja wir müssen
unbedingt weiter Energie sparen wir
bleiben auch als Koalition weiter dran
nach vielen Maßnahmen wir schon für
Energieeffizienz auf den Weg gebracht
haben auch da weiter mit dabei zu sein
und alle die in diesem Winter Energie
sparen und gerade jetzt wo es so kalt
wird ja sieht man wieder wie der
Gasverbrauch hoch geht wie wichtig ist
dass wir alle mitziehen alle die haben
hinterher noch mal richtig mehr Geld im
Geldbeutel denn jede Kilowattstunde Gas
die Sie einsparen jede Kilowattstunde
Strom die Sie einsparen da haben sie die
volle Ersparnis in Ihrem Geldbeutel drin
auch das bekommen wir hin und auch das
ist sehr gut so
wichtig wichtig ist mir aber auch dass
wir mit diesem Gesetz nicht einfach nur
sagen ja hier Geld ach und dann feiern
wir mal Weihnachten dann gucken wir mal
was passiert und oh vielleicht kommt das
nächste Problem sondern mit diesem
Gesetz sogar auch schon weiter denken
denn es muss auch immer darum gehen die
Ursache von diesem ganzen Schlamassel
die Abhängigkeit von den dramatisch
teuren fossilen Energien zu beseitigen
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
voranzubringen und auch das auch das
fassen wir in diesem Gesetz schon an und
ja es war nicht ganz einfach in der
Koalition aber es ist gelungen wir
werden den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien für die nächste Ausschreibung
entscheiden
weil nämlich die Obergrenze in den
Ausschreibungen die zu niedrig ist ja
weil auch dort Inflation herrscht weil
eben auch bei den Anlagen Infektionen
hat weil auch bei den Zinsen Inflation
herrscht weil plötzlich der Auswahl
Erneuerbaren zu mir liegen oder zum
Stoppen zu kommen drohte auch diesen
Punkt haben wir jetzt schon angegangen
denn wir können nicht auf Dauer immer
mal wieder 200 Milliarden nehmen und
entlasten nein wir müssen die Ursache
beseitigen und wir zeigen dass die Ampel
auch das und auch in diesem Gesetz schon
angeht
und auch das Kollege jung ist natürlich
die Antwort auf den Punkt den sie
inhaltlich zurecht aufgeworfen haben ich
teile Ihre Analyse dass wir dringend
bezahlbare Energie für die Industrie
besorgen müssen aber da ist doch nicht
der Punkt ob Robert Habeck sowieso ein
beinhart verhandelt in Brüssel ja noch
ein Prozentpunkt mehrere ausschlägt bei
den Punkten die Sie gerade kritisiert
haben der entscheidende Punkt ist doch
warum mir die letzten 10 Jahre so wenig
erneuerbare ausgebaut haben und dass wir
jetzt dazu hinbekommen müssen dass wir
die endlich haben und da wünsche ich mir
sehr und da freue ich mich sehr wenn wir
alle gemeinsam zusammen arbeiten denn es
ist wirklich ernst danke schön
Ingrid Nestle von den Bündnisgrünen mit
ihrem Debattenbeitrag sie Sprecherin für
Klimaschutz und Energie
fachsprecher für Energiepolitik in
Unionsfraktion ist mal Helferich und der
erhält jetzt das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen strompreisbremse gaspreisbremse
die Titel der Gesetze über die wir heute
reden drücken das genaue Gegenteil
dessen aus was sie mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit bewirken werden
nämlich den Strom und Gaspreis künstlich
hochzuhalten viel treffender wäre es das
heutige Gesetzespaket wie die FAZ das
große Geld verbrennen zu bezeichnen und
das ist es auch
warum die sogenannte Preisbremse
beinhaltet ein Mechanismus der die
Preise für Strom und Gas künstlich
hochhält eine Art Booster also ein
Beispiel Strom erklärt hier Deckel der
Staat für 80 Prozent des
vorjahresverbrauchs die Strompreise auf
40 Cent hier Kilowattstunde alles was
darüber liegt übernimmt der Staat so
weit so gut
vollkommen schräg ist allerdings ihr
Belohnungssystem Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister das einen
Anreiz zum Energiesparen setzen soll
hätten sie mal lieber den 50er
rausgerückt es wäre besser gewesen
ihr Anreizsystem sie Vereinbarungen über
20 Prozent hinausgehen eine Gutschrift
zum aktuellen Vertragspreis vor je höher
der Tarif desto größer die Entlastung
Versorger und Kunden profitieren der
Staat bezahlt an eine Pflicht den Preis
zu senken wenn es die Marktlage gebietet
hat die Ampel nicht gedacht
auch bei einem weiteren Blick in ihr
Gesetz wird deutlich die Ampel hat
grundlegende Marktprinzipien immer noch
nicht verstanden sie Deckel nämlich nur
die Preise ohne dass Angebot auszuweiten
lassen Sie mich Ihnen das einfach noch
mal ganz simpel erklären wenn alle
Bundesländer so weit wären wie das
unionsgeführte Schleswig-Holstein beim
Ausbau der Windkraft hätten wir mehr
Strom zur Verfügung und der Preis würde
sinken wenn das Rot
wenn das rot-grüne hamburg den Betrieb
des hochmodernen Kohlekraftwerks in
Moorburg nicht jahrelang torpediert
hätte könnte es heute vermutlich noch
Strom produzieren und der Preis würde
sinken wenn die Ampel die Laufzeiten
unserer Atomkraftwerke in der Krise bis
2024 verlängert hätte gäbe es mehr Strom
und der Preis würde sinken und anstatt
auf anstatt auf mehr gesicherten
Biostrom zu setzen verunsichern sie
wochenlang eine ganze Branche mit
maßlosen abschöpfungsplänen das ist rot
grün gelbe verknappungspolitik
oder um es mit den Worten unserer
Vizepräsidentin Göring-Eckardt zu sagen
das ist Wohlstand des weniger und ich
profitiere prophezeit in eines und
danach kommt nur noch Wohlstand für
weniger
meine Damen und Herren Kritik ist leider
auch notwendig an der geplanten
Entlastung für heizölpellets und
flüssiggaskunden die Union hat diese
seit Monaten eingefordert und es ist
immer noch nicht klar wann diese für
Privathaushalte kommt und dann will die
Ampel auch noch 13,5 Millionen Haushalte
in ihrer Logik Härtefälle
zur Abgabe einer eidesstattlichen
Erklärung zu ihrer brennstoffrechnung
nötigen damit setzen sie unsere Bürger
auch noch dem Risiko aus dass sie sich
unbeabsichtigt einer falschen
Versicherung an eine stadtstrafe machen
es drohen im schlimmsten
fallfreiheitsstrafen bis zu drei Jahren
oder Geldstrafe das alles müssen
Menschen auf sich nehmen um nicht zu
frieren
und für unsere kleinen und mittleren
Betriebe ist immer noch unklar wer wie
viel wann was bekommt ihm fehlt nicht
nur der wirtschaftliche Verstand sondern
auch das Herz für unseren Mittelstand
und weil Weihnachten eine Zeit der
Besinnung und des in sich Gehens ist
habe ich ihnen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister etwas
Weihnachtsgebäck aus einer
mittelständischen Familienbäckerei
mitgebracht in diesem Sinne wünsche ich
Ihnen allen besinnliche Weihnachten
[Applaus]
ja nächster Redner ist Karl Lauterbach
der Bundesgesundheitsminister da fragt
man sich im ersten Moment bei diesem
Thema hat er sich möglicherweise im
Parlament verlaufen nein er ist auch
zuständig für energiepreisbremsen denn
zusätzlich zu diesen energiepreisbremsen
soll es ein Hilfsprogramm
soll es ein Hilfsprogramm geben der
Bundesregierung über 8 Milliarden Euro
zur Dämpfung der Energiekosten der
Energiepreis Explosion für Krankenhäuser
und Pflegeheime
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben heute
eine wichtige auch eine zum Teil
technische Debatte aber ich möchte noch
einmal auf den Hintergrund dieser
Debatte zuerst zu sprechen kommen der
Hintergrund dieser Debatte ist leicht zu
beschreiben Gas Strom Energie wird
teurer und wir nehmen das hin wir werden
uns einschränken wir werden damit
klarkommen aber dass Signal was wir
heute senden und das bitte ich Sie auch
zu beachten Sie können es nach Moskau
direkt senden wir lassen uns nicht
erpressen wir lassen uns nicht der
pressen und es um die Verteidigung der
Menschenrechte geht dann werden wir uns
nicht durch die Gaspreise und die
Strompreise erpressen lassen wir stehen
jetzt zusammen und verteidigen die
Demokratie und die Menschenrechte
und ich möchte bei dieser Gelegenheit
auch noch einmal ausdrücklich dem
Kollegen Robert Habeck danken dieses
Paket hinzubekommen ein 200 Milliarden
Paket technisch sehr aufwendig für alle
Bereiche der Wirtschaft ausgreifend die
Bürger schützend umgesetzt in einer Art
und Weise dass eben nicht die Gaspreise
durch die Decke gehen dass wir nicht
durch die Unternehmen der pressbar sind
und dass das Geld auch überall im Land
ankommt das ist keine Kleinigkeit das
Verfahren ist durch die Beratung im
Bundestag besser geworden dafür bedanke
ich mich auch auch wir haben sehr viele
Änderungsanträge spät eingebracht aber
den Grundkonzeption ist vom Kollegen
Harbeck hier in einer Art und Weise
eingebracht worden wo wir sagen können
darauf können wir stolz sein das ist ein
Handwerk was erst einmal geleistet
werden muss das lässt sich leicht wenn
man noch nie ein Gesetz verantworten
muss sondern auch wahrscheinlich niemals
tun wird so wie es sich hier gestartet
lässt sich das vielleicht sagen aber
Kritik in der Sache ist richtig aber im
Grundkurs ist dieses Gesetz die
Grundlage dafür dass er durch diese
Krise hindurchkommt und zum Schluss
stärker sein werden weil es ist ein
Gesetz was gleichzeitig vorsieht dass
der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
nicht entschleunigt wird wie sehr es
sich wünschen würden und auch hier
sondern es wird beschleunigt wir werden
stärker aus dieser Krise herauskommen
als wir in die Krise hineingegangen sind
wir werden unabhängiger sein werden mehr
erneuerbare Energien
[Applaus]
lauter machen gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Bemerkung aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE von Frau Lötzsch
ich würde um Verständnis bitten bei
dieser Gelegenheit nein
ich möchte auf den zentralen Teil auch
zu sprechen kommen der unsere der unsere
krankenhausarbeiter betrifft die
Krankenhäuser und die Praxen aber auch
die Pflegeeinrichtungen kämpfen
besonders mit der Erhöhung dieser Phase
was wir hier gemacht haben nur dass das
verstanden wird wir haben hier
tatsächlich eine Regelung gefunden die
die Mehrkosten für Energie Gas und Strom
zu 100% Ausgleich wir gehen hier über
den Wirkmechanismus der gaspreisbremse
und der strompreisbremse hinaus wo ja
70% erstattet werden und bei den
Konsumenten 80%, und der Staaten hier
100%, sondern der Grundgedanke ist der
wenn wir aus dieser Krise herauskommen
dann werden wir sehen dass nicht ein
einziges Krankenhaus ist nicht deine
einzige Rehaklinik auf der Grundlage
höherer Strom und Gaspreise aus dem
Markt ausschalten das ist eine
großartige Leistung das ist der Beginn
einer
gastronomisierung unseres
Gesundheitssystems weil wir machen es
eben hier nicht so dass diejenigen die
Gewinne machen sich die höheren
Gaspreise lassen können und diejenigen
die Rücklagen haben sich die höheren
Strompreise lassen können sondern wir
Gleichnis aus für jeden wir nehmen jeden
mit das ist der Anspruch den wir hier
haben daher darf ich mich ganz herzlich
dafür bedanken auch für die konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit in dieser Hinsicht auch
ausdrücklich bei den Kollegen von der
Union die hier mitgezogen haben wir
haben zum Schluss auch noch die
Apotheker als impfstellenmaterial
gebracht auf die letzte Sekunde das ist
sinnvoll das zu machen wir müssen mehr
impfen auch gegen die Grippe und wir
haben es geschafft das Leben Verordnung
weitergeht so mit einem gutes Gesetz ich
bitte um ihre Zustimmung wir lassen uns
durch die russische
Menschenrechtsverletzung von Putin nicht
erpressen wir gehen gestärkt gemeinsam
aus dieser Krise heraus
ja wie angekündigt hat Karl Lauterbach
tatsächlich zu den Krankenhäusern
Pflegeeinrichtungen im ersten Teil der
Rede und jetzt zum Schluss allerdings
Dinge gesagt die man eigentlich eher von
Christian Lindner oder Robert Habeck
erwartet hätte beide werden in dieser
laufenden Debatte allerdings das Wort
nicht ergreifen weil ihre Zwischenfrage
nicht zugelassen wurde jetzt eine
Kurzintervention von Gesine Lötzsch von
der Fraktion DIE LINKE herzlichen Dank
Frau Präsidentin Herr Minister
lauterbach
sie hat Plenardebatte von der
Regierungsbank ausgewittert und haben
Falschbehauptung aufgestellt dazu hätte
ich sie gern gefragt sie haben in Ihrem
Tweet behauptet Klaus Ernst und die
Linke beklatschen ein Lob auf russisches
Öl das ist falsch Klaus Ernst hat die
Situation geschrieben nämlich dass der
Wohlstand der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Jahre lang Jahrzehnte lang darauf beruht
hat dass billiges Gas billiger Strom
billiges Öl exportiert wurde und zwar in
einseitiger Abhängigkeit von Russland er
hat das nicht gelobt er hat diese
Situation beschrieben und der Wohlstand
beruhte weiterhin darauf dass wir eben
teure Technologien exportieren konnten
und der Zwischenruf mit dem Porsche ist
völlig dämlich ich will darauf hinweisen
Herr Lauterbach dass sie dass sie seit
2005 seit 2005 Mitglied des Bundestages
sind und
ich würde auch meine eigene Fraktion
bitten jetzt nicht zu streiten ich will
auf jeden Fall dass Sie Herr Lauterbach
seit 2005 Mitglied des Bundestages sind
und damit etliche große Koalition
mitgetragen haben und dass sie damit mit
verantwortlich sind für die Organisation
dieser einseitigen Abhängigkeit von
Russland stehen sie zu ihrer
Verantwortung und beschimpfen sie nicht
von der Regierungsbank aus per Twitter
was sowieso eine Unsinn ist meine
Kollegen vielen Dank
da sagt noch mal jemand Debatten über
die energiepreisbremsen sein ohne
Unterhaltungswert das war die
Kurzintervention von xine rötsch jetzt
die Erwiderung von Karl Lauterbach
sondern von Gas und zum zweiten ich habe
noch nicht gesagt also
dass ich die gleichsetze sondern ich
habe darauf hingewiesen dass der Kollege
Ernst ausgedrückt hat dass wir dankbar
sein sollen dass wir diese Abhängigkeit
gehabt haben ja gesagt wir sollen
dankbar sein wir sollen der Kollege hat
gesagt wir sollen der Kollege hat
übrigens in der Kollege hat übrigens mit
Blickkontakt ausgerichtet zu den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der grünen
Partei gesagt mit Blick in die Richtung
der Grünen er hat gesagt dass wir
dankbar sein sondern dass wir von diesem
Gast profitieren dürfen das bedeutet wir
sollen dankbar sein für eine Politik die
uns eine Abhängigkeit gebracht hat von
der derzeit alle sagen können wir leiden
darunter und das das somit wenn Sie wenn
Sie jetzt wenn sie jetzt abonnieren wenn
sie jetzt monieren dass ich sage es sei
ein Lob gewesen oder ein dank gewesen
dann korrigiere ich das aber ich finde
ehrlich gesagt den dank genauso
problematisch wie das Lob wenn sie es
gelobt hätten
für alle die nicht auf Twitter unterwegs
sind müssen wir das jetzt so hinnehmen
belassen es dabei und
Plenarsitzung das würde uns allen sehr
entgegenkommen das ist die Meinung von
Bärbel Bars das hier im Plenarsaal
auszuhandelt vor laufenden Mikrofon und
Fernsehkameras und nicht über Twitter
auf diesem Social Media Kanal sind ja
auch nicht alle unterwegs nächster
Redner Konrad Stockmeyer von der FDP
Damen und Herren als Liberaler
energiepolitiker bin ich dezidiert der
Meinung dass auch der Energiemarkt
funktionieren kann wie ein Markt
eigentlich funktionieren sollte nämlich
als rechtssicherer und wettbewerblicher
Rahmen in dem sich Innovation in dem
sich auch das gewinnst Streben und in
dem sich Investitionen so entfalten dass
am besten das am Ende das bestmögliche
dabei rauskommt nämlich eine
preisgünstige sichere Energieversorgung
für Privathaushalte für Betriebe in
diesem Land und auch für Krankenhäuser
warum hebe ich heute als Liberale
energiepolitiker also meine Hand für
einen Werkzeugkasten von dem ich der
festen Überzeugung bin dass er so
schnell wie möglich wieder im Keller
verschwinden sollte warum weil es in
Zeiten des energiekrieges darum gehen
muss Schaden von diesem Land abzuwenden
warum hebe ich heute meine Hand für
Instrumente wie Erlös abschöpfungen und
Preis bremsen die nun dezidiert auf
einem funktionierenden Markt nicht zum
Einsatz kommen sollten wenn er den
funktionieren würde
warum weil es darum geht in diesen
Zeiten den Energiemarkt zu stabilisieren
preislich das funktioniert übrigens auch
schon weil es darum geht Schäden von
diesem Land abzuwenden und übrigens auch
Scherben einer Energiepolitik
staatlichen Versagens in diesem Lande
aufzukehren dass jahrelang das jahrelang
angerichtet worden ist weil wir einen
Fehler gemacht haben den wir nie wieder
machen dürfen uns nämlich einseitig in
die Abhängigkeit eines mörderischen
Regimes zu begegnen einseitig in die
Abhängigkeit von feindender Freiheit das
darf uns nie wieder passieren und das
seid und das seid Ausbruch des Krieges
auch aus diesem Hause heraus immer
wieder von der rechten Seite und ich
will Fernbleiben Ralf von Teilen der
linken Seite nicht komplett Liebesgrüße
nach Moskau geschickt werden das ist
einigermaßen unerträglich
es muss also darum gehen mit diesen
Maßnahmen heute eine Brücke zu bauen in
eine sichere und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung der Zukunft die sich
dadurch auszeichnen sollte dass sie
übrigens nicht nur in einem deutschen
sondern in einem europäischen Sinne so
dezentral wie möglich organisiert ist
sowohl in der Produzenten als auch in
der Eigentümerstruktur dass sie flexibel
ist und jawohl dass sie für privates
Kapital auch attraktive Ertragschancen
bietet und dass sie sich technologisch
vielfältig gestaltet es ist überhaupt
keine Zeit dafür dabei zu verlieren
diese Aufgabe anzupacken wir als Freie
Demokraten werden da ganz konstruktiv
mitwirken danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
Konrad Stockmeier von der FDP ist schon
der zweite FDP-Abgeordnete der sozusagen
im selbstbesichtigungsmodus hier im
Bundestag Auftritt dass die
energiepreisbremsen doch das
ordnungspolitische Modell der FDP Arcen
nächster Redner Andreas Mehltretter von
der SPD
meine Damen und Herren die preisbremsen
kommen das was wir versprochen haben das
setzen wir heute um wir lassen niemanden
allein wir schützen viele Betriebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor den Kosten
die sie nicht tragen können und wir
geben damit die richtige jetzt
kurzfristig notwendige Antwort auf die
Energiekrise
wir geben aber auch die Antwort die
mittel und langfristig notwendig ist die
Zukunft unserer Energieversorgung muss
erneuerbar sein Strom und Wärme aus
Sonne Wind Wasser und Biomasse senken
schon heute die Preise sie machen uns
unabhängig von Rohstoffimporten der
Schlüssel für zukünftig sichere und
bezahlbare Energie sind gute
Investitionsbedingungen für Wind und
Solaranlagen
deswegen geben wir der Bundesnetzagentur
bei der Erneuerbaren Förderung den
Spielraum den sie braucht um auf die
gestiegenen Kosten zu reagieren Wind und
Solar bleiben die günstigsten
Stromerzeuger aber auch dort macht sich
die Inflation bemerkbar die
Bundesnetzagentur kann jetzt die
Ausschreibungen so gestalten dass wir
unsere ausbaummengen die wir uns
vorgenommen haben auch erreichen können
das ist ein extrem wichtiger Schritt für
die erneuerbaren Energien und ein extrem
wichtiger Schritt für eine sichere und
preiswerte Energieversorgung meine Damen
und Herren
wir stellen auch sicher dass die
sinnvolle und notwendige Abschöpfung von
überschusserlösen den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren eben nicht bremst es ist
richtig überschusserlöse wegen der
Energie wegen der Energiekrise entstehen
auch bei erneuerbaren Energien
abzuschöpfen das gehört zur gerechten
Finanzierung der Preis Bremsen zum
Beispiel bei Biogasanlagen aber war der
sogenannte Sicherheitszuschlag zu
niedrig für einen kostendeckenden im
Betrieb wir haben diesen
Sicherheitszuschlag deswegen auf 19
erhöht damit ist gewährleistet dass die
Biogasanlagen auch weiterhin mit voller
Kraft Strom produzieren
meine Damen und Herren die preisbremsen
wirken schnell das ist es was gerade im
Vordergrund stehen muss wir haben in den
Beratungen aber auch feststellen müssen
dass wir nicht alles sofort lösen können
die Gasversorger wissen zum Beispiel
nicht wie viele Haushalte denn an einem
Anschluss hängen deshalb geht manches
was die Bremsen gerechter machen würde
im Moment nicht es geht noch nicht das
Modell der Preis Bremsen soll aber eben
ein lernendes Modell sein mit dem wir in
Zukunft noch zielgerichteter
unterstützen können deshalb fordern wir
die Bundesregierung auch auf bis zum
Sommer zu prüfen wie Einkommens ärmere
sparsame Haushalte besser entlastet
werden können etwa mit einem
haushaltsbezogenen Basis Kontingent und
die Bundesregierung muss untersuchen wie
mit einer Obergrenze verhindert werden
könnte das reiche Haushalte mit
übermäßig hohem Verbrauch übermäßige
Subventionen bekommen dadurch wollen wir
die gaspreisbremse noch gerechter
meine Damen und Herren es ist bereits
darauf hingewiesen worden ein ebenso
zentraler Punkt für die Gerechtigkeit
ist dass wir auch die nicht alleine
lassen die mit Öl mit Pellets oder mit
Flüssiggas heizen auch wer solche
Brennstoffe für die Heizung kaufen
musste soll bei einer Belastung die über
dem doppelten liegt des vorwiesenniveaus
eine Entlastung bekommen können so geht
gerechte Politik in der Energiekrise
meine Damen und Herren die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in unserem Land erwarten dass
wir alles dafür tun dass Energie
bezahlbar bleibt deswegen hat es mich
doch sehr verwundert dass CDU und CSU im
Ausschuss die preisbremsen abgelehnt
haben und das heute ja anscheinend
wieder tun wollen das zeigt wo
wirtschaftsverstand und Herz für den
Mittelstand wirklich fehlende hilfreich
wir stellen heute sicher das Energie
bezahlbar bleibt und mit den ab mit der
Abstimmung wird deutlich wärs mit den
Entlastungen ernst meint wir als Ampel
jedenfalls zeigen wir lassen niemanden
allein
Andreas mehltwetter aus dem Wahlkreis
Freising der nächste Regner kommt aus
dem benachbarten Wahlkreis Erding
Ebersberg allerdings nicht von der SPD
sondern von der Unionsfraktion Andreas
Sprecher für Energie und Nachhaltigkeit
der CSU Landesgruppe
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zunächst einmal am Ende der
Debatte lässt sich doch feststellen es
ist immer mit einer gewissen Vorsicht zu
genießen wenn der
Bundesgesundheitsminister über
Energiepolitik spricht und
und dieser dieser Fakt wirkt wirft auch
ein gewisses Licht auf das Verfahren des
stattfand
ab zunächst einmal ist es doch zu
betonen dass es gut ist grundsätzlich
das Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlastet
werden und wir waren und sind nicht
gegen Entlastungen im Gegenteil wir
fordern diese Zeit beginnt dieses Jahres
so und ich kann es ihnen nicht ersparen
sie haben viel Zeit vergeudet die
unsägliche Diskussion der Streit um die
gasumlage die weder umsetzbar noch
verfassungsgemäß war die viel Geld
verschwendet hat ich war neulich bei den
Stadtwerken in Augsburg aus Beispiel
allein diese Stadtwerke mussten 150.000
Euro aufwenden für eine gasumlage die
nie kam hier wurde die Murks und der
Murks ging weiter bei der Gas und
strompreisbremse fast 400 Seiten die am
Morgen des Mittwochs des gestrigen
mittwochs kamen sind kein Zeichen für
Respekt gegenüber dem Parlament aber
auch nicht für ein Zeichen von Respekt
gegenüber den Betroffenen
zuerst zuerst wollten sie die
Erneuerbaren rückwirkend zum ersten
dritten abschöpfen dann zum 1.9 jetzt
zum ersten 12 das schafft erhebliche
Verunsicherung die derzeitige
Investitions Zurückhaltung bei den
Erneuerbaren geht auch auf ihre Politik
zurück sehr geehrte Damen und Herren und
wenn ich jetzt sehe das PPA ist das
letzten Endes quasi ja
Vertragsverhältnisse ausgebremst werden
und dadurch Innovationen ausgebremst
werden bei den Erneuerbaren Stichwort
Wunsiedel wasserstoffregion dann ist es
auch ihr Verantwortung dass diese
Projekte nicht stattfinden ebenso haben
sie die Branche der Bioenergie
verunsichert ja in Existenz
Existenzängste versetzt sehr erhöhen
zwar jetzt den Sicherheitszuschlag
altholzanlagen haben aber nach wie vor
große Probleme als Beispiel Steinkohle
wird nicht abgeschöpft nachhaltige
Bioenergie schon das muss man sich mal
vorstellen klüger wäre es die Bioenergie
ganz aus der Abschöpfung auszunehmen wie
wir das entsprechend fordern
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von Frau
läßle von Bündnis 90 die Grünen nein es
ist wichtig Inhaber von Holzpellet
Heizungen von Heizöl von
flüssiggasheizungen ebenfalls zu
entlasten auch das fordern wir seit
Beginn der Debatte ob der vor in Höhe
von 1,8 Milliarden Euro aber ausreicht
das ist mir das ist mehr als fraglich
sorgen sie für eine entsprechende
Finanzierung der Hilfen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
noch noch ist übrigens überhaupt nicht
sicher ob das Geld ob die Hilfen auch
tatsächlich bei den Unternehmen ankommen
noch ist nicht sicher ob damit
Arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben laut die
die laut Bibi sind die Hilfen vielfach
überhaupt nicht anwendbares liegt am
Beihilferecht aber nicht nur das liegt
auch an der Komplexität die Anwendung
setzen Sie sich dafür ein dass die
Beihilfe dass das Beihilfe recht
ermöglicht und nicht verhindert dass die
Industrie dass der Standard Deutschland
einen Zug eine Zukunft hat sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
und es hieß ja vorher das gewisse Dinge
corona-fälle in 2021 das hochwasserfälle
berücksichtigt werden können in Gesetz
steht dazu übrigens noch gar nichts auch
die Besteuerung steht nicht im Gesetz
sondern nur in einem
Entschließungsantrag und es ist eben so
dass die gerechtigkeitsdefizite noch
nach wie vor vorhanden sind und
gesetzlich nicht gelöst sind am besten
gegen hohe Preise ist ein hohes Angebot
das geht auch und gerade bei der Energie
durch den Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft zum
15 April erreichen Sie genau das
Gegenteil ihre Politik trägt dazu bei
dass im Moment
rekordmengen von Gas verstromt werden es
wurde noch nie so viel Gas verstrom wie
im Moment 20% des Stroms kommen aus
Gaskraftwerken das muss man sich auch
mal vorstellen und letzten Endes
brauchen wir natürlich einen massiven
aus bei der Erneuerbaren aber immer auch
ein Backup durch im Moment eben
konventionelle Kraftwerke das ist die
Verantwortung um entsprechend
Energiesicherheit zu geben herzlichen
Dank
wir haben sicherlich gerade alle
mitbekommen gesehen und gehört im
Präsidium hat gewechselt
von der ebenfalls von der SPD hat jetzt
Bärbel Bars als Präsidentin als
amtierende Präsidentin der laufenden
Sitzung abgelöst die voraussichtlich
letzte Rednerin dieser Debatte über die
energiepreisbremsen vor der Abstimmung
ist Zander Martens von der SPD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Parteien Liebe
Mieterinnen und Mieter Deutschland ist
das Niederland Nummer eins in der EU
nirgendwo ist die Eigentumsquote
niedriger mehr als die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung kann sich wohl Eigentum
nicht leisten und lebt hierzulande zur
mieten auch Düsseldorf mein Wahlkreis
ist eine Mieter statt dort leben sogar
80 Prozent zu mieten
niedrige und Mieter sind in unserem Land
also die übergroße Mehrheit an
MieterInnen sollten wir daher in der
Politik immer denken das Recht auf
Wohnraum achten die Mieten bezahlbar
halten und sie in Krisenzeiten entlasten
damit MieterInnen die nicht selbst mit
ihrem Energieversorger direkt sondern
über den Vermieter abrechnen zum
Beispiel in zentralbeheizten Häusern
damit sie nicht schlechter behandelt
werden als alle anderen waren für uns
jetzt nicht nur wegen Weihnachten drei
Wünsche besonders wichtig und für die
haben wir gekämpft erstens die
MieterInnen werden rückwirkend auch für
Januar und Februar entlastet und die
Weitergabe die Weitergabe der
Entlastungen an die MieterInnen
betreffen nicht nur die die mit Gas und
Fernwärme heizen sondern auch alle die
mit Strom heizen auch mit Wärmepumpe
oder Nachtspeicherheizung der
Entlastungen kommen also allen
Niederländerinnen zu Gute alles andere
wäre auch zutiefst ungerecht gewesen
zweitens muss der Vermieter die
Betriebskosten Vorauszahlung
unverzüglich anpassen nicht erst nach
der Betriebskostenabrechnung für 2023
die schlimmstenfalls erst Ende 24 kommt
fast der Vermieter sich beeilt um die
turnusmäßige Jahresabrechnung für dieses
Jahr bis zum 1 April 23 fertiggestellt
kann die Anpassung der Betriebskosten
Vorauszahlung gemeinsam mit der
Jahresabrechnung erfolgen spätestens
dann muss dabei die Betriebskosten
Vorauszahlung auf jeden Fall angepasst
sein
drittens brauchen die MieterInnen nicht
selbst aktiv zu werden sie müssen die
Entlastungen nicht selbst errechnen und
dem Vermieter Anzeigen das war uns
wichtig denn wir wissen doch genau dass
gerade auf dem heutigen Wohnungsmarkt
Mieter und Vermieter nicht auf Augenhöhe
sind Mieter sind allzu oft nur heilfroh
überhaupt eine Bleibe gefunden zu haben
und sogar noch eine bezahlbare kaum
einen Mieter legt sich doch heute
freiwillig mit dem Vermieter an deshalb
war also eine klare Verpflichtung der
Vermieter für uns ein politisches muss
wenn wir wollen dass die Entlastungen
bei den MieterInnen tatsächlich ankommen
und das wollen wir
bei allen Kompromissen bei anderen
Kompromissen die unter drei
Koalitionspartnern notwendig sind allein
schon wegen dieser drei Wünsche die wir
den MieterInnen jetzt erfüllen können
wir mit gutem Gewissen sagen wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass MieterInnen gerade
die mit kleinem oder mittlerem Einkommen
im mieterland Deutschland schnell direkt
und unkompliziert bei Gas Wärme und
Strompreisen entlastet werden frohe
Festtage
soweit Zander Martens von der SPD und
jetzt kommt es zur Verabschiedung dieses
Gesetzes mit entschließungs- und
Änderungsanträgen mir liegt nach unserer
Geschäftsordnung Paragraph 31 eine
Erklärung vor und wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über den von den Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Einführung von Preis Bremsen für
leitungsgebundenes Erdgas und Wärme und
Veränderung sonstiger Vorschriften der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
könnte die Regierungsbank auch ein wenig
zuhören der Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 49/11 den Gesetzentwurf der
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP auf Drucksache 4683 in der
ausschussfassung anzunehmen die Fraktion
der AFD hat beantragt über den
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
getrennt abzustimmen und zwar zum einen
über Artikel 9 bis Artikel 13 und
Artikel 15 Absatz 3 und 4 des
Gesetzentwurfs in der ausschussfassung
dazu gehören die Änderung des fünften
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch
desinfektionsschutzgesetzes des
apothekengesetzes und der
Apothekenbetriebsordnung und zum anderen
über den Gesetzentwurf im übrigen
ich rufe zunächst auf die Artikel 9 bis
Artikel 13 und Artikel 15 Absatz 3 und 4
ich bitte nun diejenigen die Artikel 9
bis Artikel 13 und Artikel 15 Absatz 3
und 4 das ist Gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschussfassung zustimmen wollen um das
Anzeichen
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90/grün und FDP
wer stimmt dagegen das ist die cdu/csu
und die AFD wer enthält sich das ist DIE
LINKE damit sind Artikel 9 bis Artikel
13 und Artikel 15 Absatz 3 und 4
angenommen ich rufe nun auf die übrigen
Teile des Gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschussfassung wer möchte den übrigen
Teilen des Gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschussfassung zustimmen
das ist wieder die SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu wer enthält sich die linke und
die AFD damit ist sind alle Teile des
Gesetzentwurfs in zweiter Beratung
angenommen hier geht es jetzt um die
gaspreisbremse die damit angenommen
worden ist in gesetzesformen die
Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP haben namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt
unmittelbar nach Eröffnung der
namentlichen schlussabstimmungs stimmen
wir noch über eine Entschließung des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
sowie über den Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion der CDU CSU ab
deswegen bitte ich die Abgeordneten im
Saal noch hier zu bleiben die Abstimmung
erfolgt wie wir es ja kennen in der
westlobby sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer
Architektur durch mich die Abstimmung
findet natürlich namentlich statt jetzt
war ja nur eine Abstimmung darüber in
welcher Form die einzelnen Paragraphen
Abschnitte dieses Gesetzes abgestimmt
werden sollen die namentliche Abstimmung
wird natürlich erst das Ergebnis bringen
es besteht aber kein Zweifel daran dass
ich die Ampelkoalition bei
gaspreisbremse und später dann bei der
strompreisbremse durchsetzt und
bevorstehende Ende wird auch wieder
bekannt gegeben
so unter Buchstabe b seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 49 11
empfiehlt der Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie eine Entschließung
anzunehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung das ist DIE LINKE
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP wer
stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu und AFD Enthaltungen keine die
Beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen wir
kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
CDU CSU auf Drucksache 49 13 wer stimmt
dafür
das ist die cdu/csu wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Gründe
und FDP wer enthält sich die linke und
die AFD der Entschließungsantrag ist
abgelehnt dieser Entschließungsantrag
der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion bezog sich
auf die gaspreisbremse
jetzt folgenden Zusatzpunkt 3